♪ Ooooh ♪
♪ Wowowowow... ♪
♪ You know that
I have been waiting ♪
♪ Had these feelings
For so long ♪
♪ Had to feel so right, baby ♪
♪ How could this feeling
Be wrong? ♪
♪ Sometimes the thing that
You've been searching for ♪
♪ Has been right there
The whole time ♪
♪ So, baby
I'm here to tell ya ♪
♪ I'm waiting right here
Just to make you all mine ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ You're the one ♪
♪ I've always longed for ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ It's a feeling I can't hide ♪
♪ And I've always been
Your baby ♪
♪ Standing right here
By your side ♪
♪ Yeah, it's been building up
Inside of me ♪
♪ And I just gotta
To come out ♪
♪ And tell you
What I'm feeling, girl ♪
♪ Tell you our love
Is what I'm talking about ♪
♪ I... gotta tell you
Where my heart goes ♪
♪ And what it has known
For so long ♪
♪ I finally need to show you ♪
♪ My arms are wide open
That's where you belong ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-You know ♪
♪ I'll make love to you gently
♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ The way I've seen it
In my mind ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ I will take care
Of you, baby ♪
♪ There ain't no rush, baby
Let's take our sweet time ♪
♪ I'll do it to you slow
♪ The new way
You've never done before ♪
♪ Open up your mind
I will open up your door ♪
♪ I've been searching
All around ♪
♪ For the one I can call mine ♪
♪ Sometimes the thing
You're searching for ♪
♪ Has been there
The whole time ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ I wanna give you ♪
♪ All I got now ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ And I'll take
All you can give ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ And I'll never turn
My back on you ♪
♪ As long
As we both shall live ♪
♪ I'm talking about you ♪
♪ You, standing
Right in front of you ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ Whoo! Nothing left to hide ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ Sugar, say I'm telling you ♪
♪ Everything I've kept
Very deep inside ♪
♪ I'm rubbing up against ♪
♪ Your big bald head
Your big bald head ♪
♪ I say your big bald head,
N-N-Nah ♪
♪ There's no one else
♪ I could be
Possibly talking about ♪
♪ 'Cause you are bald
And you are here ♪
[music continues,
silence in the audience]
♪ You... ♪
♪ You're a woman
I'm a man, now ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ And you know
That's how I like it ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ And I'm specifically
Talking about ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ Because you're a girl ♪
♪ And I am the opposite ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ Woman, woman
♪ Woman, woman, woman ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ You are a woman I am a man ♪
-♪ You know I like women ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ Because I am a man ♪
♪ You... ♪
♪ Never liked a man
In my life before ♪
-♪ You... ♪
-♪ And I don't like one now ♪